set in the spectacular landscape of the
best kitty mountains the silhouette of a
house there makes it immediately clear
it was designed by an architect who
likes to experiment the building has two
roofs one at the top and one reaching
down to the ground
the facade is very minimalist the
architect Robert Kanye's house is
considered one of the most modern
residential projects in Poland welcome
to my art it's very foggy today very
little furniture soft colors and
straight lines ensure a peaceful
ambience huge windows dominate the room
an elegant and ingenious fireplace
offers warmth and coziness for Robert
Cooney a teeny design isn't the
essential feature here no interior
design should be simple and calm and not
distract from what's happening outside
the house we have a very nice view from
this side and from the other side and it
changes every day even the fog today is
magical as if we were in heaven
what should you make with cool
the main entrance is opened by remote
control so that you reach the house the
architect's ark as if via a jetty it
looks as if it's just making a brief
stop on the mountain slope
the wall on one side of the house can be
moved as necessary to make best use of
the natural light in the living room if
I were to build a garden or a terrace
here or put up a fence let alone plant
something it would look strange and
totally inappropriate with my idea you
get the feeling that you own in a whole
mountain the house is floating on the
mountain there are no borders here the
building has about 140 square meters of
living space and was designed in such a
way as to allow the water coming from
the mountains to flow off naturally
underneath it there is no foundation the
house stands on three pillars these are
hidden from view by a screen that looks
like a second roof which creates the ark
like form after the architect moved in
the word Ark took on a second meaning
for him animals don't mind this house in
summer they come and sleep near it but
now in winter they stay in the forest
ecological aspects also played an
important role in planning the house for
example
Kanye Cheney sprayed the inside walls
with a protective foam that gives a
special look to the bathroom and the
walls can store heat better a both
minimalist and very functional design my
house should be in symbiosis with nature
I can not fight it with technology
the architecture and design magazine
wallpaper has named Robert Kayne Chinese
Ark the best private home of 2017 the
Polish architect had no intention of
winning prizes with the house he was
just looking for a place of refuge from
hectic city life and created it here